the numbers are shocking Biden
Administration officials privately
revealing to lawmakers an average of
5,000 illegal immigrants are being
released into the US every single day
our next guest has covered the Border
crisis firsthand Sunday morning Futures
anchor Maria bartar Romo joins us now
those numbers and Maria we can get lost
in numbers but inside of those numbers
who knows National Security threats you
know fundamental changes to the country
over time the numbers get staggering
they really do will good morning to you
the pictures are staggering as well I've
been watching the show this morning and
the pictures that you showed of just
what took place over the weekend in
Texas and Arizona are staggering and of
course we know that on Joe Biden's watch
8 million people have come into America
be been apprehended as well as gotten
away uh so even more stunning are the
number of people that we see on
surveillance video that have entered the
country and have gotten away we have no
idea what they're doing what their
intentions are and of course the ones
that we have apprehended some are on
terrorist watch lists you have to ask
yourself why why is this Administration
allowing this incredible dereliction of
Duty why does Joe Biden have this
incredible derel of Duty what about
Alejandra mayorcas what is their goal uh
it's clearly a national security threat
we're all worried about it not just
human trafficking uh but also drug
trafficking 100,000 Americans are dead
because of fentanyl that have come into
the country so there's a report today
after New York uh Republican uh malot
tacus had a press conference over the
weekend in Staten Island she's a New
York representative and she said that
she has a portion of a contract she
submitted a request for the Freedom of
Information law to access an agreement
between New York City and the homes for
the homeless which manages the migrant
facility on Staten Island she says a
portion of that contract shows that it
obligates contractors of Migrant shelter
to hand out voter registration cards and
she's saying that uh they are obligated
to help the migrants in registering to
vote circulate campaign materials within
the shelter premises Nicole motakis gave
a press conference about this so you
have to wonder is that really what it is
is that why we have this wide openen
border putting our country in such a
vulnerable position national security
threat to American citizens because they
think that these people will eventually
become voters of the Democrat Party I
don't know I don't have the answer I
don't have the answer so why they are
allowing this der elction of Duty at our
Southern border I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis